previously on hunter x hunter phantom
troop attack auction house in the york
new city to steal the treasures but fail
since the treasure room was empty after
defeating all the shadow beasts sent by
mafia they catch owl and take the
treasure from him after being free from
his comrades ubo swears to kill
korathika after he was captured and
humiliated by him
the story continues with ubo finally
finding kurapika the two go to a
deserted wasteland where the tension
increases after getting rid of the
leeches inside his body ubo asks his
opponent who he is since he senses that
he isn't an ordinary man-user karapika
asks before answering if ubo and the
phantom troop remember the people they
killed he answers he can only remember
certain people that made an impression
understanding now kurepika wants revenge
as korapika reminds him of the kurta
clan was the troop massacre five years
ago and their scarlet eyes ubel can't
remember a thing about them but confirms
that he was a member of the troop five
years ago
ubo makes the first move
karapika evades his attack and uses his
chains multiple times but ubo dodges
everyone realizing how dangerous the
chains are in feeling an abnormal men
coming from them ubo comes up with an
idea he needs to strike first to get an
advantage he runs directly to kora
korapika and throws a hard punch that
damages korapika's left arm
however korapika quickly counters with
his chains that ubo manages to avoid
while figuring out what type of nen
korapika has korapika insults him by
saying his punch is weak hubo angrily
goes to half strength and runs towards
him kurapika evades his attack counters
and hits ubo
korapika then dares ubo views his full
strength
in response ubu does so and punches the
ground causing a smokescreen
he sneaks up on korapika and lands a
full-strength big bang impact that
completely breaks his left arm
after kurapika praises him about his nen
he uses his own men to trap ubo with his
chains and explains how he got captured
figuring out korapika's type of nen uber
wonders if he mastered both enhancer and
conjuration techniques
kurapika stands in front of him and
removes his contact lenses revealing his
scarlet eyes
seeing this umo finally remembers the
clan stating that they were really tough
and their boss really wanted those eyes
lubo becomes firing up again and tries
to break free from the chains wrapped
around him he keeps trying but fails as
corapica tells him when his eyes turn
scarlet he's a specialist and when he is
in that state he can gain full control
of the other types of men
in a flashback karapika discusses using
chains with his teacher for his attack
he also makes a condition on the chain
so they can't break against the spiders
and sets a rule that will risk his life
back in the present korapigab
demonstrates his power by using a chain
to fully heal his left arm he tells ubo
why he chose him as his first target the
reasons being that he is the strongest
in terms of physical strength from what
he saw against the foreshadow beasts and
if he can't break through his chains
then the other spiders would be left
helpless
furthermore the chain jail activates
zetsu and ensnares any troop member and
that explains why ubo can't break
through using his aura lubo tries to
break the chain again now using his
physical strength alone karapika punches
ubo piercing through his steel body he
is convinced that he can beat any troop
member when they are wrapped in his
chain jail he inquires ubo about the
troops location and abilities but he
refuses to answer instead he asks
koratpika to kill him
he uses his judgment chain wrapping it
around ubo's heart
kurapika explains the judgment chain if
ubel breaks the rules he sets the knife
will activate and pierce through ugo's
heart
then core rapica asks him again where
the troop is hiding instead of answering
uber smiles and tells korapika to die
the judgment chain activates and crushes
hubo's heart after the fight korapika
makes a call to melody and buries ubo's
body in the ground
back in the phantom truth's hideout all
the remaining members of the troop
gather and listen to crawlow their
leader deduces that if whomever ubo is
after uses a chain then it's highly
likely that his enemy is either a
manipulator or a conjurer
crawler tells the team that ubo can hold
his own in a fight but these two types
would give ubo the most trouble and have
the highest chance of killing him in a
one-on-one fight
it's common practice for conjurers to
give special abilities and properties to
their creations and some of the special
abilities and properties could cancel
ubo's strength out and a manipulator
could manipulate ubo himself
crawler then states that they will wait
until dawn if uvo has not returned by
then then they will change their plans
gon kilua and lee oreo pursue the
phantom troupe as gohan uses his hunter
license to make money and gather
information about the troop and greed
island
on the way gon notices a knife in the
market as killua explains that it is one
of ben's knives from a famous blacksmith
gone uses his geo and sees an aura
flowing around it killua acknowledges
this but lidorio can't see since he
doesn't know anything about nen yet
killua remembers that their nen teacher
wing told them real talented people use
nen without even realizing it and they
may be able to earn money by collecting
these rare items with men they also find
a box with wooden statue and later meet
sep pile who agrees to help them with
the trade of the rare item they find
gon kilua and liorio head to the
location where two phantom troop members
were spotted arriving at the area the
trio watched machi and nobunaga at a
distance the spiders discussed what
could have happened to their comrade ubo
while planning their next move
mashi and nobunaga wonder if ubo is dead
or not kiluad explains to leorio why
it's impossible for them to catch two
troop members recalling something that
his father said when he fought one he
complained that the price wasn't enough
as kiluah says that is the greatest
compliment a target can get machi and
nobunaga are aware someone's watching
them making them think it is korapika
and nobonaville will stick to the rules
that their boss told them to capture and
bring the chain user back dead or alive
shall narc and crawler gather
information about the nostrade family
knowing that the chain user is working
for them and crawler becomes interested
in nostrade
at the hotel lightnostrade advises his
bodyguards to keep his daughters safe at
all costs
he gives orders to basho and melody to
bring his daughter back to their way
home promising her she'll go to an
auction one day when she leaves the room
light informs his guards that the
underground auction will resume at night
as the tendons vow to reclaim the lost
items
regarding the stolen items koratpika
mentions the shadow beast who took the
items beforehand but light informs them
that all the shadow beasts have been
wiped out except for owl who is the one
holding the items for auction light
believes that he was captured by the
troop the ten dons assume that the
stolen items are already in the troops
hand and this is why they hire
professional assassins to get rid of the
troop
no straight orders koratpika to join the
assassins to hunt the troop as it will
give them a chance to make a name for
themselves
machi and nobunando make their move and
the three start to plan deciding gon and
killual will tail him the tailing starts
when nobunaga and maichi move gon and
killua following the great caution the
two realize they are being followed and
are quite impressed with their skills
since they can't sense a thing as the
tailing continues killua realizes that
the two already know they're being
followed and are heading to a deserted
area
he starts making assumptions whether
it's a trap or are they going back to
the hideout as kilua decides to continue
their pursuit
machi and nobunaga stop in the middle of
a deserted place surrounded by abandoned
buildings acknowledging the ones
following them can't be the chain user
since he assumes that he works alone
considering he works for the no stray
family yet he fought ubo alone since
nothing has happened nobunaga thinks the
chain user killed ubo without reporting
to the mafia and use revenge as a motive
machi rejects that and believes the ones
following them have some connection with
the chain user
gum and kilua talk on the phone
believing that they are trying to lure
them out when suddenly nobody's phone
rings
nobody suddenly looks directly toward
kilua's location
both gon and killua quickly make an
escape but the doors are blocked by
thinx and pakinoda
kiluah uses his speed and bounces around
the room but finx easily grabs his leg
killua grabs stones and throws them
towards finks as a distraction
immediately following a kick that is
also easily caught by thinx
killua pierces the ground with his
fingers spinning until he escaped from
fink's grass but behind him is nobunaga
gone is surrounded by machi and pakunoda
asking him if he knows the chain user
not knowing yet that the chain user is
kurapika nobunava asks and why they're
following them and killua has no choice
but to answer the mafia put a huge
bounty on them telling them who taught
him men in questions he knows anyone
using chains
killua says he has no idea who that is
making nobunaga ask his last question
whether he wants to die now or later
having only three seconds to answer
gon tries to escape barely moving an
inch before getting caught by machi and
pacquinoda gets a call saying kiluah has
surrendered on the waves that are
hideout the troop asks the same
questions and the two have the same
answers they finally arrived at the
hideout meeting the rest of the troop
and in more danger than ever gon and
kalula are now in the phantom troop base
surrounded by the members not knowing
what they'll do to them both boys notice
ahsoka but the three pretend not to know
each other nobody wonders if they know
any of the troop in kiluah notices
shizuku franklin and fight and recognize
gone as the armed wrestler nobunaga
challenges gone to arm wrestle and
continues to pound gone's hand into
concrete hurting it nogunava talks of
his friendship with ubo as he knew him
better than any other troop member and
even begins to cry
he vows to find the chain user no matter
what he knows the nose trades hired him
and then he holds a grudge against the
troop which makes killer piece together
who it could be
gone reiterates that he knows nothing
and suddenly in a rage and activating
his men gon voicing how he could have
emotional feelings to mourn a friend at
the same time murders so many others gon
slams nobunaga's hand down this time
prompting fighting to restrain him from
behind
kiluet takes a step towards gohan hisoka
holds a card to his neck to not break
appearances franklin asked pakone if
they knew anything but her nen ability
didn't find any memories of the chain
user kiluad deduces pakino to check
their memories by touching them which is
bad because now that killua has an idea
that the chain user might be kurupika
some troop members want to let them go
but fink still has an inkling they may
not know since the chain user hides his
chains
shallmark comes up with the idea to find
more information about the no stray
family since they know he works for them
after everything is decided nobunaga
asks gone to join the phantom troop but
gon boldly states that he would rather
die
he just laughs guessing that gome is an
enhancer and wants to ask crollo if they
both can join however nobuname is tasked
to watch them
franklin mentions to the others that gon
remind him of ubo he fought strongest
when it was for someone else much like
the feeling they get from gone
shaolin gives out flyers of all the
bodyguards working for nostrade
they pair up to find the chain user and
since nobody is staying behind machi is
stuck with hisoka much to her dismay
in a prison-like setting nobody is
watching gon and killua gon holds his
hand in pain killuel loses himself for a
moment standing up and releasing a good
amount of aura nobody never laughs
thinking that it's a challenge and
killua tries to walk towards him but
freezes in a cold sweat eventually
walking back powerless
he punches a wall in anger and gone
thinks of a way of escape
they charge their nan in rush towards
nobonada who prepares to kill them but
instead both crash through the walls of
the room in opposite directions nobody
chases gone but is tricked by a hole in
the wall that leads to nowhere gum and
killua have already escaped leaving the
building and heading back to york new
city they still want to defeat the
phantom troop but know they must get a
lot stronger to do so killua tells gone
that korapika is the chain user and
figures he's the best person to ask
about the troop
while shopping no straight is able to
escape from her servants and bodyguards
meanwhile a man who seems to give
competition to lightnose trade names
zenji gathers assassins which includes
sola xeno and korapika to take care of
the phantom troop
after the assassins have made a decision
zenji mock's light no straight but stops
when threatened by kurapika until light
tells him to cease now traveling to the
auction korapika receives a call from
basho and melody regarding no straight
escaping from them
light hears the news of his daughter and
gets immensely worried but corapica
locates her using his dowsing chain
light then immediately alerts the police
and guards not to let his daughter enter
the auction building
nostrade with the help of crawlow is
able to get past the security and goes
inside the building where the auction is
held
like it's an update about his daughter
that she has entered the auction house
and gets worried about her safety
meanwhile crawler chats with no straight
about her fortune telling skill and asks
her if she can foretell this fortune to
which mistreat agrees when she finishes
her ability crolo reads the first verse
of the paper and tears flow from his
eyes by saying that all of the things
foretold are true it essentially says
he'll mourn for lost comrades be injured
but will remain strong to find new
teammates the two then leave the
restaurant while talking he tells
nostrade that he believes in ghosts
referring to ubo and in memory of him
goes wild
he then knocks no straight out lightning
quick after knocking her out crawlow
acts concerned and asks for help from
the security
in the monitor operating room of the
building assassinate asks an operator to
rewind the scene where nostrada
collapses and sees crolo striking her
korapika and light arrive at the
building and go straight to nostrade
kurapika tells light to leave the place
with basho and melody and tells him that
the auction will not be held since the
place will be turned into a battlefield
assassinate locates crawler who already
disposed of another assassin tells
assassinate to show himself and invites
him to fight one-on-one frighten tells
finks about the message he receives from
their boss telling them to go wild while
getting to the cemetery building where
the auction is supposed to be held
finks asks him about the others and
fight in replies that they are on their
way to the cemetery but they are
cleaning up trash while approaching the
building
other members of the troop except hizoka
who watches from afar are seen in the
streets of york new city disposing all
the police and mafia members meanwhile
crawler uses his net ability indoor fish
on assassinate which has torn his body
to pieces but kept him alive crawlow
opens the window and assassin a is
instantly killed per the rule of the
ability crawlow while stating a prophecy
that's been foretold to him performs a
musical composition by shedding blood
dedicated to ubo
the end of part 7 be sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell to not
miss the next part